en alabama 6000 salariés d'amazon ont
voté le 29 mars pour la création d'un
syndicat les employés se plaignaient de
cadences infernales d'un bonus accordé
puis retiré de poses trop courte
rien de plus naturel que de se syndiquer
me direz vous et bien non car c'est
historique c'est une première pour la
compagnie de jeff bezos ce aux états
unis deux précédente tentative avait
échoué et le parcours pour aboutir à ce
vote su semer d'embûches car ces
aspirants à la lutte sociale se sont vus
exhorté par amazon de renoncer à ce
projet les employés ont reçu des sms sur
les avantages sociaux dont ils
bénéficient ou des textos de critiques à
l'encontre des syndicalistes de
l'entreprise
on a tenté de les décourager en
expliquant que les grèves allait leur
faire perdre de l'argent
amazon est même accusé par un média
américain d'avoir changé la vitesse d'un
feu tricolore à la sortie du site pour
que syndicaliste et chauffeurs ne puisse
plus échangées mais c'est sur les
réseaux sociaux que l'entreprise de
commerce en ligne a montré l'étendue de
son talent en matière d' offensive anti
syndicale des vidéos ont ainsi surgi sur
twitter
ils prennent juste ton argent ils ne
font rien pour toi je n'ai pas besoin
d'un syndicat je vais voter non et si un
syndicat s'implantait ce serait une
catastrophe
à la base on a tout ce qu'il faut ici
j'ai toujours voulu travailler pour
amazon c'est la seule entreprise que je
connaisse dont on tire le bénéfice au
1er jour je vais voter non au syndicat
je vais voter nos on en a pas besoin
sur twitter même combat dès 2018 alors
que certains salariés d'amazon critiquer
leurs conditions de travail
tu es content d'employé modèle se
multiplier il se montrait extrêmement
ravis de travailler pour l'entreprise et
on faisait tout naturellement les
louanges
saviez-vous qu amazon fait les employés
de ces entrepôts 30% de plus que les
autres entreprises marchandes je me sens
fier de travailler pour amazon qui ont
pris soin de moi bien plus que mes
employeurs précédents
problème plusieurs d'entre eux ou
changer de nom au fil des mois où
étaient suspendus bizarre mais il existe
bien de véritables ambassadeurs d'amazon
ils font partie d'un programme appelé
tenez vous bien veritas sauf que
l'enthousiaste ça se monnaie selon yahoo
finance ses employés qui ne travaillait
d'ailleurs pas toujours dans les
entrepôts étaient gratifiés d'un jour de
congé supplémentaire et recevait un bon
d'achat de 50 dollars pour passer un peu
de cirage le site d'investigation
belling cats a ainsi identifié 56
comptes actifs ou non de ses
ambassadeurs alors serait ce par manque
de combattants que les dirigeants
d'amazon vont eux mêmes au front le
patron opérationnel de l'entreprise dave
clark livrent bataille sur twitter avec
les démocrates
bernie sanders ans un candidat à la
présidentielle prévoyez de venir
encourager les futurs syndicaliste
d'alabama
dave clark s'est alors vanté d'avoir mis
en place depuis bien longtemps
ce que le sénateur de gauche réclament
donc si vous voulez entendre parler
d'environ 15 $ de l'heure et de soins de
santé
le sénateur sanders va prendre la parole
dans le centre ville mais si vous
souhaitez gagner 15 $ de l'heure au
minimum et bénéficier de bons soins de
santé amazon recrutent les résultats du
vote pour valider ce premier syndicat
d'amazon seront connus ces jours ci mais
la brèche a bel et bien été créé des
salariés de 50 entrepôt ont fait
connaître leur intention de former un
syndicat mais leurs camarades de france
pour leur faire part de leur expérience
le média américain weiss a dévoilé des
documents mails et des rapports secrets
révélant une surveillance accrue des
syndicalistes français de la plateforme
via une unité de sécurité maison digne
d'un film d'espionnage
c'est de notoriété publique l'amazone
n'a jamais été un long fleuve tranquille